i suppose you're right huh yeah so what
i gotta ask
is like when whole life english got
announced
i don't like on on my end of things and
i've been following whole life since
kind of the beginning of the year
i had no idea how big hollow life
english was going to become
were you expecting the response or like
your fellow your fellow
hollow life english cast members would
you were you guys expecting the response
that you got
well it's interesting because i actually
we talked about this
many times we actually had no idea uh
how we would be received right because
it's not like the five of us are the
first um english-speaking
girls that have done work with polo live
right i mean there are several
whole alive girls that are able to speak
pretty good english so we weren't sure
because um no i suppose
how should i say this it's it's been
difficult
to estimate i suppose how well in
english english
yes exactly an english group of
youtubers would appeal to an
english-speaking
audience because those who came before
us have done well of course but
but it's hard to tell because we're the
first
mainly english speaking right right
right so
we basically had no idea is what i'm
trying to say in my long-winded
explanation absolutely no sense because
i'm a bit of a scattered brain everyone
knows this mystery so like did you
did you like all like all the whole life
english members did you guys like meet
beforehand like before all the reveals
were happening nope
oh so so you me so you met each other
like after you debuted
oh no we met before we debuted but this
has been we were working together for a
very long time beforehand right
and kind of getting to know each other
and and i i technically yes i got to
meet the other girls but before that
um we were all just kind of shoved into
the same room and it was like hello nice
to meet you all of you you are my
teammates
that's just so weird because like that's
the equivalent of like getting a bunch
of antitubers you've never met being
like all right you're all starting a
podcast
exactly well it turned out okay because
all of the other girls are
very um very laid back and we all have
personalities that um
that work really well with each other
and it's never it's never weird we all
like each other a lot so
so that's cool i suppose uh we just got
lucky maybe maybe that's what it is we
just got super lucky i mean i think so
from like from the
from what i've seen like all the whole
live english members they seem to
work well you guys seem to work well
together and you guys seem to have like
very distinct personalities as well
yeah i know i know yeah what do you
think of this connor
it's good